Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see that virtual bones
make everything better.
This new paper is about setting up bones and
joints for our virtual characters to be able
to compute deformations.
Deformations are at the heart of computer
animation, look, all of these sequences require
a carefully designed technique that can move
these joints around and simulate its effect
on the entirety of the body.
Things move around, stretch, and bulge.
But, there is a problem.
What’s the problem?
Well, even with state of the art deformation
techniques, sometimes, this happens.
Did you catch it?
There is the problem, look!
The hip region unfortunately bulges inwards.
Is this specific to this technique?
No-no, not in the slightest - pretty much
all of the previous techniques showcase that
to some effect.
This is perhaps our most intense case of this
inward bulging.
So, let’s have a taste of the new method.
How does it deal with a case like this?
Perfectly, that’s how.
Loving it.
Now, hold on to your papers, because it works
by creating something that the authors refer
to as virtual bones.
Let’s look under the hood and locate them.
There they are!
These red dots showcase these virtual bones.
We can set them up as a parameter and the
algorithm distributes them automatically.
Here, we have a 100 of them, but we can go
to 200, or, if we so desire, we can request
even 500 of them.
So, what difference does this make?
With a 100 virtual bones.
Let’s see…yes.
Here you see that the cooler colors like blue
showcase the regions that are deforming accurately,
and the warmer colors, for instance, red showcases
the problematic regions where the technique
did not perform well.
The red part means that these deformations
can be off by about 2 centimeters, or about
three quarters of an inch.
I would say that is great news, because even
even with only a 100 virtual bones, we get
an acceptable animation.
However, the technique is still somewhat inaccurate
around the knee and the hips.
However, if you are one of our really precise
Fellow Scholars, and feel that even that tiny
mismatch is too much, we can raise the number
of virtual bones to 500, and, let’s see…there
we go!
Still some imperfections around the knees,
but, the rest is accurate to a small fraction
of an inch.
Excellent.
The hips and knees seem to be a common theme,
look, they show up in this example too.
And, as in the previous case, even the 100
virtual bone animation is acceptable, and
most of the problems can be remedied by adding
500 of them.
Still some issues around the elbows.
So far, we have looked at the new solution,
and marked the good and bad regions with heatmaps.
So now, how about looking at the reference
footage and the new technique side by side.
Why?
Because we’ll find out whether it is just
good at fooling the human eye, or does it
really match up?
Let’s have a look together.
This is linear blend skinning, a state of
the art method.
For now, we can accept this as a reference.
Note that setting this up is expensive both
in terms of computation, and it also requires
a skilled artist to place these helper joints
correctly.
This looks great.
So how does the new method with the virtual
bones look under the hood?
These correspond to those, so, why do all
this?
Because the new method can be computed much,
much cheaper.
So let’s see what the results look like!
Mmmm!
Yeah!
Very close to the reference results.
Absolutely amazing.
Now, let’s run a torture test that would
make any computer graphics researcher blush.
Oh my.
There are so many characters here animated
at the same time.
So how long do we have to wait for these accurate
simulations?
Minutes to hours?
Let me know your guess in the comments below.
I’ll wait.
Thank you!
Now, hold on to your papers because all this
takes about 5 milliseconds per frame.
5 milliseconds!
This seems well over a hundred characters
rocking out, and the new technique doesn’t
even break a sweat.
So, I hope that with this, computer animations
are going to become a lot more realistic in
the near future.
What a time to be alive!
Also, make sure to have a look at the paper
in the video description.
I loved the beautiful mathematics, and the
clarity in there.
It clearly states the contributions in a bulleted
list, which is a more and more common occurrence,
that’s good, but look!
It even provides an image of these contributions
right there, making it even clearer to the
reader.
Generally, details like this show that the
authors went out of their way and spent a
great deal of extra time writing a crystal-clear
paper.
It takes much, much more time than many may
imagine, so, I would like to send big thank
you to the authors for that.
Way
to go!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!